Film Courage: Despite your love for film, going back
to CLOSE ENCOUNTERS, seeing it, this being
this magical experience, at one point you
really thought you would never be a
filmmaker, director, not even short films
for fun? Jason Satterlund, Filmmaker: Yeah, I mean you know it's my
case and probably the case of every
filmmaker out there you you you see that
spark and you love it you fight and you
sacrifice everything to get there and
you do it you do it you do it and then
it doesn't quite happen the way you
think you're not plucked out of
obscurity like some of these guys are
you're still working in the trenches for
years and it's a little I can't get
frustrating and then in my case I did a
film that had a lot of controversy
around it and was never ultimately
released and it was so utterly
devastating because after so many years
of just working and working and working
it's sacrifice this film looked like it
was gonna really be something and then
instead it's not released and there's a
lot of controversy and bad press and all
these ugly things and it just it
devastated me so much that I I I didn't
know if it was worth it and I circled
the drain because it's hard to go from
something like that from a film that was
so artistically satisfying such a great
script and all these things to go from
that to going back to trying to find
work as a doing more corporate stuff
like us like how do you even what am I
to do
like I circled the drain for a long time
like it it because my life was not
turning out the way I thought it would
and this is everyone's story right
everyone like we all think we know how
it's gonna turn out any wife does this
to you and goes back this way and you
know so for a few years I didn't know my
wife suggested to me maybe we should
just sell everything and go teach
English in Korea and I seriously thought
about it and it got to a point with me
where I had to just it stripped
everything away from me and got me back
to the basics of what do I really love
it forced
right take another look at what do I
love about the film industry in
filmmaking and storytelling in I found
that spark again like I just I love
moving people and crafting stories and
I'd love to see people laugh when
they're supposed to work jump when
they're supposed like I have worked my
whole life for that if there's no
feeling and no I don't know anything
else I couldn't do anything else and I
and I also had to you know and take it
experience and try to see all the good
that came out of it because a lot of
good did he and move forward which is
it's not easy but you know it yeah
that's the other thing they don't tell
you in film school is what happens when
discouragement hits cuz it does like it
can you know especially when the success
doesn't comic when you think it will you
know or it builds up to it and feels
like you're being blamed or something I
mean there is like and I started this
way by saying this air is we are sold on
this idea that that filmmaking will
happen in a certain way like the Duplass
brothers were speaking in an S Film
Festival years ago whatever I saw I read
this article somewhere and they said
here's what you do you make your film
for 500 bucks and then you get
distribution on it you'll make some
money on it then you make your second
film and you put a big star in it and
that'll do well on the festival circuit
yeah well it might happen that way but
it might not for most people that's not
how it happens you'll make your film and
you'll mortgage your house and then
nothing happens that's so common that
was all the time the film disappeared on
Netflix and that's the end and now what
and you know you're not discovered and
you're not picked from obscurity and so
then what do you do from there do you
keep going how much do you really love
this how hard are you willing to write
that next script get the next one going
to fight for the next client with
everything you've got and fight that
cynicism that wants to just rare it's
ugly little head
yeah that's that's where the love of it
will really you better discover it you
better know why you love it and I do
think it's worth fighting for all the
negativity all the challenges all the
frustrations is worth fighting through
to get there because it really is great
like when you're on set and it's working
and you're telling that story and the
actors are there the cinematography look
nothing it's so like all of that
disappears and just fades away and
you're just like wow I'm creating this
amazing moment and it's working yeah
it's worth fighting for no question do
you think that was the main good that
came out is knowing how bad you wanted
to fight for it knowing that you could
have packed up and nothing wrong with
teaching but there's nothing wrong with
it just wouldn't have been you have been
thinking about the film's you wanted to
make yeah okay guys let's let's take out
our notebooks and then I had to be
stripped back to the basics and go back
to rediscovering what I loved and yeah
that's I think that's healthy sometimes
I think it's good to do you know
struggle is good hard work is good it's
an it can be a real positive thing
doesn't feel good when you're in it but
afterwards anyone who's ever struggled
usually looks back and says it was a
good thing I mean you look at like David
Sanborn famous saxophone player had
polio as a kid you know and he started
playing he's the doctor told him as a
kid he either needed to start some sort
of exercise like swimming or a wind
instrument so he picks up saxophone
James Earl Jones had a stutter and now
he's the voice of Darth Vader with them
one of the most memorable voices all
because he had to work his voice and
work through that struggle to get there
most people who do great that Nelson
Mandela I'm reading his book right now
like the struggles he went through and
he became one of the most inspiring
leaders in the world because of the
struggles he went through and how great
that made him as a leader like struggles
good it's positive thing I just watched
the Miles Davis documentary
it was great and just dad didn't want
him to be a jazz musician he came from
sort of a wealthy family and just all
the things that he went through he
didn't want to come back to the states
he really wanted to be in Paris where
all the artists were and just his whole
journey he had to reinvent himself
several times within sort of that genre
and there were a few years where he just
put down his instruments and wouldn't he
wouldn't do anything and he fell prey to
drugs and just they thought he was done
and then turned out he wasn't you know
and he reinvented himself
you interested and he just kind of
talked about how a great artists always
have to keep reinventing they can't stay
stagnant yeah I mean you've talked about
filmmakers being in a rut have you ever
felt you know what what do you do to
shake things up you know it's funny
about the rut so like everyone looks at
the thought well I mean success of life
but filmmaking in specific we all look
at it like this mountain that we're
climbing and we're looking at the peak
you know all of it now if I could direct
the next Marvel movie or whatever that's
the peak well I don't see it that way I
think we're all ants crawling across the
plowed field it's flat and it goes like
this
and it's an ant climbing over that first
little rise might be landing your first
gig maybe maybe it's landing any gig
right you press that heel and oh we're
doing infill and then you you know then
immediately as soon as you get there you
look at the next gig the next maybe the
next mountain is directing for the first
time right well you get it you cross
over and you get any of it so you know
that's normal that's what we all we're
all ants crawling crosses filled with
our own little goals and things that
we're trying to do well what can happen
is this let's say your first gig you
land your first gig and it's working for
reality television as an editor
perfectly respectable job you know well
you get over that rise and you end up in
that little pocket that's and you're
safe from the wind and you're not
struggling to make the rent and but if
you're not careful you'll stay there
because what can happen is is you'll end
up five years later and oh man you know
there's that
next rise right in front of me that that
rise was to write that feature
screenplay I've always meant to write
and I never have done it because I'm too
busy editing for reality television or
whatever that that's your route every
time you crest one of those things and
you end up in the safeness of the trough
it can become a rut if you are not
careful now I'm not saying that editing
for reality television is a bad thing
it's purely on your own perception on
where you want to be and also because
the playing field is level you know cuz
maybe you want to go several um humps
over and get to say making directing for
television doing all the whatever the
latest TV show is CSI or what that's not
even on anymore I don't think over here
well maybe you don't you get there you
don't like it and you want to go back
and teach you go back across the field
you're not going down you're making a
lateral move over here to go something
that you enjoy if you just love to
making documentaries more than you ever
loved doing television and that's
totally fine and you know but though
that's how it like every every success
can become a rut and you just need to
this is why I think this is why I made
the commitment years ago to absolutely
make sure I'm making a forward step
every single day some sort of either
writing that screenplay reading an
article in American cinematographer
watching a film courage video or
whatever it is you know like doing
something to continually hone and
improve your craft every single day I
don't care how hard you tired you are
you know it keep improving keep growing
keep pushing and striving and all of a
sudden one day you're gonna realize
you've mastered it do you know when
you're in a rut when you've all I think
oh you do sometimes it takes it might
take someone to wake you up
I think people somewhere deep inside you
know I think a lot of us feel that we're
already in a rut I think if you're not
being challenged
that's a big sign if you're going to
work and it's just kind of uh it's no
longer hard that's a that's a
sign probably means that you're there
yeah and or if you done is is hard to
say I would say if you've done the same
thing for a long time and never changed
but I don't mean that having a job for a
long time is a negative thing I mean
like if you're just doing the same thing
over and over and never it's rying
something new within even with let's say
you're a teacher and you just teach out
of the same book for 20 years without
ever researching something else or
trying new teaching methods or
experimenting with different ways
looking at what worked and what didn't
work and changing it up sometimes I
think that's important because you can
stag
you